hey y'all before we start this video we
just want to acknowledge that this is
obviously a very sensitive topic
especially coming out of what's been
an incredibly difficult year battling
the coronavirus pandemic
but as vaccines are starting to roll out
this is also a very real
and current conversation that we're
seeing happen within our communities and
all around the country
so our goal with this video was to just
earnestly
portray various perspectives that we're
hearing and
um not necessarily that we condone these
perspectives but to
understand why people are feeling the
way they might be as always
please seek out experts as you're making
your own decisions and above all else
we want to encourage you to see each
other's humanity
and feel more empathy enjoy the video
over the past year i've been integrally
involved in treating coping 19 patients
in the icu as i'm a critical care
physician
i'd never seen a disease like this in my
20 years of experience
this virus kills you slowly methodically
and without mercy
i'm a registered nurse and i think the
covered vaccine is very important
because it prevents infection and
not just for us and for for our families
we've all been
at home for the better part of a year
and
we have to make some tough decisions
about our health and how we're going to
interact with each other
in the future
[Music]
why am i skeptical well there's been a
lot of misinformation
this covet thing has been very political
i'm not
anti-vaccination i'm just more skeptical
about the cove
vaccination i feel like it's not safe
yet there hasn't been enough testing
done on this vaccine and i don't think
that it's a one size fits all
i'm not for the covet vaccine because
the evidence doesn't add up to
that being necessary in order to survive
there's only been one side of the story
towed and it's been a sign of death
and sadness and depression and i don't
believe that's the whole truth
[Music]
hi my name is jacqueline i'm a
registered nurse for
two years and i'm excited to be here and
extremely nervous
my name is thomas yadagar i'm a critical
care physician and i supervise a team of
20 physicians
and on a normal day we take care of
about 120 patients in a hospital and
about 40 to 50 patients in icu
hi my name is kelly i am a teacher i've
been teaching for
16 years and i'm just very excited to be
here
hi my name is siaka massaqua and you
know just a
individual that loves this life and
wants to just see the best for everybody
in it you know
hello my name is percy i'm an actor and
podcaster and i'm just grateful to be
here
hi my name is erica and i am a
stay-at-home mom
i have a four-year-old i'm definitely
not here to change anyone's mind but
just to share my own personal experience
and my
views on things can i please have my pro
covered vaccine folks on the left
and my skeptics on the right
the first prompt is covid19
scares me please come forward if you
agree with the statement
yeah so for me i have asthma i was born
with it which is why i keep myself
isolated i just don't want to put myself
in the position where i got to call my
mom and say hey
come to california i'm in trouble yeah
for me
covid with family members
friends who have gotten sick friends who
have passed away
i'm just very concerned for my parents
my aunts my
cousins everybody so including myself
i actually work with covid patients
since the very beginning so i'm also
scared
that i can contact from my patients and
i can give it to my parents
i think the thing that scares me most
about covet is that it is
so unpredictable yeah a year ago when
this started
the first patient in l.a county came to
our hospital 13 people that were on a
ski trip in italy
and when i walked into the room to talk
to him about it what he told me he
kind of made the hair on my back of my
neck stand up
yeah seven of them ended up getting
hospitalized
two of them were on a respirator we're
on blood pressure medicines on ecmo
fighting for their lives
and these are people in their 40s 50s
60s that right off the bat
caused me to call all my relatives and
tell them
stay the hell home be careful hunker
down
despite being in cameras i'm actually
intensely private at this
it really this is not something that i'm
comfortable with
but i uh started posting things on
facebook to
alert people to the threats of what was
coming our way
because this is no ordinary virus
okay can we please have our disagreers
come and join us
i thought i was going to be the only one
i guess i would say it doesn't scare me
in the same
[Music]
manner as i've heard from you guys
because i had it i got it back in
january before it was cool
yeah i'm good now right my 74 year old
mom who came to visit had it my
six-year-old got son my three-year-old
godson my 40 year old
best friend 32 year old roommate
the kids went through like this my mom
11 days
it was weird for her but she's healthy
as hell you know and
and that's my own personal story and i
have not changed my lifestyle
since this thing started if anything
i've gone out more i've been going to
rallies since june
and i've been around multiple people of
all ages consistently hugged
hung out with every saturday for six
seven months
nothing but yet i'm only being told one
side of the story
well for me it's not really a fear um
because i grew up undocumented so
there's a lot of other things that i
grew up fearing um
cops being one of those and covet
you know it got my grandmother i got um
my aunt
my uncle my aunt and uncle did pass away
in mexico
um it got a handful of my friends
but to say that i'm afraid of it and to
like change my life
and stay home and then feed that to my
four-year-old
that's not the way that i have chosen to
live
because i do agree that fear in itself
can cause so much stress it can
lower your immune system you know and it
can just put your mind in such a state
of panic
and trauma that i feel like that in
itself can be so much
more detrimental in the long run i think
that's that's my big issue with it
because i i just
after this thing then what when we're
not we're too afraid to come up to
strangers
yeah like how are we supposed to do
stuff you should be aware
i don't think it's ever good to you know
to cause
mass fear on on the population but i i
think
you know knowledge is power so you have
to
be able to understand what's going on
around you and adapt around you
what what i've had to do with my
students is to make them aware
of it being okay have you gone outside
today did you go get some fresh air okay
let's do some exercises do a plank
competition in the house at least
something that's active because they are
so
recluse and that's the part that is
concerning
yeah within the first few weeks i uh one
of my doctors asked me to see a patient
she'd been into the emergency room three
times within a week she was convinced
she had coveted
and she had some of the symptoms she had
chest tightness shortness of breath
and they were going to do a fourth test
her three previous ones were all
negative
so i walked in and i'm like you have any
kids she's like yeah i have a 10 month
old but he's fine don't worry about him
i'm like
what do you mean he's fine don't worry
about him she's like
i use clorox i just make sure that this
virus doesn't come anywhere around
i'm like what about with your groceries
she's like my groceries i use bleach on
them
i told her i'm like you know i looked at
your cats again you don't have covet
but you have a chemical pneumonitis yes
from all this
bleach from all these chemicals that you
have introduced you just put yourself in
harm
and like go home do what you normally do
in terms of wash your hands
you know some of the stuff that was
coming out in the first few weeks
it lingers in the air for three hours it
lasts on
you know surfaces for three days and i'm
looking at the tv and i'm telling my
wife i'm like
this is nonsense yeah what this is a
respiratory virus
i like i just feel like it has been
blown
to a proportion that it doesn't need to
be yes be safe be cautious
but you don't have to run around you
know bleaching your vegetables like you
know
what is that doing i would just say like
take it seriously don't wait until
your mom or your grandmother's in the
hospital say oh you know take cover
seriously because we've been seeing that
all year
and it's not getting us nowhere everyone
should get a coven 19 vaccine
okay come forward if you disagree
shot the moon
i don't think everybody should get it
because people who are allergic to
vaccines
obviously shouldn't get the vaccine but
i feel like i can see how much covid can
affect
family members and i see like my grandma
actually passed away with
kovid um she was a nursing home that's
how she got it i feel like
herd immunity i think it it could give
us back to normal life
yeah i mean i think getting a vaccine is
incredibly
individual choice right so we all have
our own medical history
we all have our own medical experiences
how we react to tubercines
that being said i don't think at this
point we're going to
eradicate copen19 with a vaccine but
that doesn't mean that vaccine is not
critically important and the people who
should be getting it they should
get the vaccine i myself did get the
vaccine
yeah i agree i don't think it's a one
size fits all because again everyone's
body is so different that what might
work for you
might kill me and vice versa and so for
me i feel like that's not
a risk that i'm willing to take i
actually developed allergies due to
vaccines as a kid
and i would break out in hives it would
last
you know anywhere between three days to
like two weeks and the doctors
throughout like
20 years of my life could never figure
it out it definitely does something to
you
mentally when you go into an er and
you're in this desperate need for help
and
they would just kind of look at me and
go like okay well we'll just give you
benadryl and
you can go home it wasn't until i became
an adult
i worked for several families as a
babysitter and they all happen to be
physicians and
some of them talk to me about vaccine
injuries it it clicked you know
because the second that i started making
my own medical decisions
that's when all of these side effects
just kind of
went away that's unfortunate because you
didn't
get the care that you should have gotten
like i didn't hear
or know about vaccine injury beca
until i started really working in health
care and public health and
i have friends who have autoimmune
issues and they have
big allergic reactions to certain things
and so they have a huge concern about
of course this vaccine cova vaccine
because
you know what could happen the one thing
i would ask you though erica is because
you have had family members that died
yeah so you would trust getting the
disease
versus the vaccine the vaccine scares
you that much that you would
rather get there like let's say if you
had covid like i would feel so much more
comfortable
shaking your hand and getting covered
through you and build the antibodies for
it
then i would to trust the vaccine i
remember the last episode i had i was
in my closet and this is when i knew it
was really bad because my thoughts were
getting really dark to where i
visualized myself cutting off each hive
so would i risk going back there again
for this with this vaccine i just
wouldn't um i think again
with your experience of having the
vaccines it totally makes sense but
my recommendation would be please don't
get it naturally you know do everything
you can to
even prevent yourself from getting it
and the one thing that you guys haven't
seen
unfortunately i think jacqueline and i
have seen it
the death that comes with kovid it's not
a romantic
death it's not noble it's a miserable
gruesome death and all you can do
not for hours but for days and weeks is
to sit there
and tell every single person that comes
into your room
help me help me i can't breathe
for weeks and weeks this virus pushes
you so far beyond your limit
that you give up you give up on the one
thing that i can't give you medication
for
hope you give up hope
and your soul gives up the will to live
the will to fight
and i think that's the hardest part to
explain to people that
yes you know you guys are young but the
problem is this virus
needs you to spread
and when it spreads it lands on someone
someone named
daniel who at 59 loses his life and
doesn't get to attend his daughter's
wedding doesn't get to walk her down the
aisle
it lands on someone evaristo who's a 61
year old guy healthy
his only problem was he went to work at
whole foods and he checked
people's temperature and when he finally
died his
thigh was the size of my wrist no matter
what i did i couldn't
stop it i couldn't help them and
i've had patients where they had it and
you know they're like well
i had it it wasn't bad and they went to
see their you know their relative
and their relative ends up you know on
life support so i think that's why it's
so important to get vaccinated is
it's not for yourself it's for the
people that you don't know but you're
going to come into contact with and
you're going to help this virus spread
but isn't that under the assumption that
the vaccination itself somehow stops you
from getting coveted and that's not true
the vaccination actually both the pfizer
and the modern are very successful
at 94 can you still get it yes i have
had patients that have had
their series of vaccines and even two
weeks later they still get
the virus but even when you get it it's
not as severe you don't need to get
hospitalized
and again if we can break the cycle
where there's less people for this virus
to spread
that's what we're looking for in the
vaccination i guess with me on that
um if we're talking about the mortality
rate is is uh
0.3 0.03 percent you know for who we're
dying that survivor is 99.97
the death rate is higher at that point
it's one to two percent actually the
death
of the two percent so if it's around
99.99
not 99.97 case fatality rates are about
in the in states is about one percent
yeah i didn't think it was even a
percentage point what doesn't add up is
to take that foreign entity that has so
many other things that can affect my
body in a negative way that i don't need
to put in myself
for what i'm looking at as the
percentage of
those that when they do get it this is
who may go
so i see covet patients every day at
work
surviving is different from thriving i
see patients all the time that
can't even breathe on their own the rest
of their life they have to
be on oxygen sure they didn't die but
now they can't walk up the stairs
without feeling shortness of breath
how many is that it's about 30 about 30
and those are not even hospitalized
patients so even people who
had mild illness they developed long
yeah
30 yeah up to 30 i saw all the different
age ranges in my house and nobody has
anything after it affects people in
different ways
exactly and i mean it's not to take away
like man that's terrible
but what it can do adversely to me and
to others it's going to be
impossible to approach it from your
perspective because i'm not seeing those
patients right
all the things you guys are saying i
don't believe is false at all
that's your experience right but i also
know it's like i told you i'm going out
week in
and week out seeing those old people for
six seven months and we're laughing
partying dancing together consistently
i can't just shut that off and go all
the time said this and then cnn said
this and
only the people in the front lines right
when those are dying said this so that
means that's the only truth i mean you
can hear the frustration
you know it's just a lot of political
nonsense going on they're not telling us
what the vaccine is made out of
you know they're not telling us the side
effects we're handed about on twitter
people know sitting in bed you know it
can't get out because they gotta you
know their body hurt so for me
it's just like what is the line about
what was the political agenda about
it makes you not trust yeah no i hear
you i hear you and i think
um what's always attracted me to
medicine you have to make your decisions
based on
facts not fear not speculation not
political agendas
but the truth of it was when this
started in march a lot of my friends
started asking me because they said oh
there's going to be a vaccine and i'm
like
there's going to be a vaccine it's going
to take at least two years
the earliest that we had developed a
vaccine before was four years but then
in the summertime it actually went
through phase one and phase two
and then it went in to start getting
phase three and the reason why it was
actually
able to get done within a year period is
because one they cut all the red tape
because there's a lot of bureaucracy but
then there was also a tremendous amount
of collaboration
right between countries so i posted when
i got my vaccine in december
and some of my friends called me and
they're like you said it wasn't going to
be available and you said also
when it becomes available you're going
to wait three to six months to get it
what what made you change your mind i
said listen over this past
year i have seen what this virus can do
to people
the reason why you don't know the side
effects is because it is a
not fully fda approved vaccination
right you're putting your faith into
something because you know
and have trusted a variety of other
vaccinations over the course of the
years and you know
and you trust the steps and the stages
that these different companies went
through in order to
eliminate a virus that is that is
running rampant
over the world i think one of the things
that really hasn't been publicized
is the quote-unquote side effects the
vaccine the pfizer and the modern are
two shots
so the first shot is just to get your
immune system kind of used to it and the
second shot is a booster
so the symptoms that you get the
headache the body aches
the low-grade fever that's actually not
a side effect
that's your immune system working and
they go away
i understand that you know you had a
horrible response and it was much more
severe but
for the vast majority of people we've
already vaccinated over 100 million
people
across the globe so i think if there was
anything more serious it would have come
out well then there's i mean i'm sure
everyone's seen videos and they're
people who are saying i'm a nurse
i did this another side of their face is
flat or they're shaking all day
when you see and you look up and you're
online and that information that stuff
gets
censored and taken off youtube taking
off instagram taking off facebook
like it then it it raises that if you
look at like
tuskegee experiment they sat there and
shot up a bunch of black men to berkeley
or with um telling they didn't say
anything and they've been doing this
consistently we can talk about like
smallpox blankets
right and it's like we've seen what
they've done
and then when you see people get
censored for having a different opinion
on this stuff
over the last 10 months it makes it that
much harder that
when they say take the vaccination i'd
be damned to listen to them
i'm not saying you're a liar i'm not
saying you're lying i'm not saying
you're a liar but i'm like
you're also saying the same thing the
same people who i've seen
show us get shot on tv like it's a it's
a sport
right like what is that doing to the
psyche of our country it's still coming
from these people or from a group that
you go
you don't have confidence in that you
know and i think that's the biggest
issue is the lack of transparency and
trust right
i don't think they're doing anymore but
remember they came out and it was like
oh we'll pay people 1500
yeah to take the vaccine but isn't this
the same government that every time we
need a stimulus check they can't come up
with a deal but
you know they're willing to pay for i
again it just looks fishy it smells
fishy
they're not telling us anything can i
ask you a question so
let's say everybody got the vaccine what
happens do we just
go back to work go back to the gyms go
back to school like unless the vaccine
works 100
and we all take it i mean what happens
like do we go back to normal do we still
get a way to face mass or social
distance well to continue to wear
mass because there are people that
aren't going to be vaccinated and there
are people that are going to continue to
spread covet 19
because that's just what viruses do they
spread and we're not going back to
normal
we're going to go to some new variation
we're going to have our own variant
of normalcy and we're creating those
things right now as we
do the process and opening back up i
know that my district is
planning to do soft open you still have
to be
aware though that these kids they don't
have a vaccine so
you know my students are coming back
into the classroom are they going to be
passing it to each other because guess
what
a lot of them have had covid over this
break you asked a really good question
this is like if everyone in america gets
vaccinated those things go back to
normal
and i think the honest truth is we don't
know what's going to happen in six
months
now this one you know the mortality rate
is like one to two percent maybe a
little bit lower
what if the variants come up to 10 15
now that's a game changer what if it
gets to be like ebola
where it kills 40 of the people this
virus is just so tricky so elusive it
just changes so much
this is an evolving pandemic it's like
nothing that we've ever seen before
i think they should just be honest yeah
you know as opposed to saying
well this is what you need to do so we
can open the schools
just be honest the coven 19 restrictions
have been necessary
i mean i guess okay
peer pressure huh i think it has been
necessary
when we look at how it's passed around
right the gym i love the gym
i used to live in a gym and i know
there's a chance that people don't wipe
off
after their equipment people don't wash
their hands in the bathroom you know so
i think the restrictions have been
necessary because if if we didn't close
down people would still be at the
beaches having a good old time
we needed some type of structure to make
us do it because
if the government just said you know
it's up to you to stay home
people don't even do it now and i mean
if we get another shutdown
it might be necessary who knows but i
think for the time being it has helped
slow the spread of goldman in regards to
the shutdown for my students
it's put them into a whole other state
of mind actually
in terms of their ability to communicate
with people and with each other
it was like something had triggered
because they were doing okay before and
then all of a sudden
they just shut down that's a big concern
of mine the shutdown is is a little bit
long
and possibly could have been staggered
or um
altered in different ways like okay
let's open and then during those times
of
the fall winter you know season perhaps
maybe we can you know close it back down
for the two to three weeks
i think initially when we didn't know
what was going on
like hey i mean i was riding around with
them with a mask on but then we started
finding out and they didn't adjust
that was my problem like my local
restaurant my buddy owns a shut down but
i get on a flight from here to chicago
with strangers i don't know completely
fine
that doesn't make sense to me i think
it's the basis of what this country is
about
it's your decision yeah we would want it
to be
up to the individual person why do i
have to take all of these restrictions
on my body
if a i'm taking care of my health and b
i'm being smart about how i
interact you know i spend money on all
of those green
vegan meals you know i'm like i'm not
doing all of this work
for nothing i don't know it feels really
interesting because i feel like
i am the only one in the people i know
that
is like i'm not gonna wear a mask and
like i'm not afraid of kovit but i'm not
going to the clubs
you know i mean and i feel like
sometimes when we think of people that
don't wear masks you just assume that
they're out there throwing parties and
but it's like i'm you're right so
i feel like sometimes we're generalizing
and throwing people into these
boxes and then making these big
assumptions then that creates this sense
of fear because then i'm going to be
thinking like well you have it and you
have it and you have it because you're
not wearing a mask
i think the issue i'm having is i'm not
trying to label
all non-mass wares as just criminals and
they
should be locked up but i remember
bioware had a concert in atlanta a
couple weeks ago
and you see videos and pictures of
people just i mean
wow it just smells hot all those people
in that club
pack together like sardines somebody has
cloven they either
pass it along or they take it home you
see like that that whole thing like i
just i can't get aboard with that
because it's all still based on fear
it's also based on like well because you
said you saw the party that means
somebody got sick and i'm like i'm
seeing the people that
bought in like 100 then come out and
then
something happens and it's like well you
were locked up you weren't getting sun
you weren't doing things you're
interacting like that blows my mind
that made us weaker that's not the case
that's not the case with the last no no
lockdowns have done worse in the cities
and in the states than the ones that
have less lockdown but then we had a
third wave that was
way worse that wasn't a lockdown the
restaurants were open i know because i
wasn't there but friends were
inviting me to go let's go out and eat
and then their third wave came and
that's when the shutdown happened in
november
and so i don't agree with the lockdowns
create more
viruses they actually stop them because
obviously we're not seeing
it doesn't add up you saw the numbers
drop in the hospitals as that shutdown
happened
and that's why we're back in this whole
opened up again yeah
so i believe the lockdown was really
necessary i think the
first wave it was kind of controlled we
only had
one medical surgical floor that had
coped and then the third search with
halloween christmas
new year's we had four floors
that were all for covid so people were
just laying
in a room bagged up because the morgue
is full and you're that's taking away
a potential bed for another patient yeah
i mean i think
um the lockdown we had in march
in april was a strict lockdown
you would see four cars in the 101. that
was
la you could drive yeah that was fun i
mean that was extended for a couple of
months and i think we all agreed i was a
little too long
but we didn't really have those types of
lockdowns again
i remember vividly coming home before
thanksgiving and telling my wife i'm
like this is gonna get really bad
she's like what are you talking about
i'm like i just drove onto 101
and i was in rush hour traffic it felt
like
last year before it felt like no one
really believes that there's this
pandemic again
within a three-week span we went from 15
to 20 to 120 patients
with covet and unfortunately you know it
cost a lot of lives we lost 10 000
people in l.a county
from march to december 31st
in 2021 we've lost another 37 000.
right 10 000 all of last year from kovid
37 just
in a month and a half of 2021. if we
would have had strict lockdowns for two
weeks
around the christmas around new year's
if they would have done that i think we
would have cut down on the
deaths i think conversation is the most
important way to solve a problem
we can be actually the virus right and
we can interject
some healing for ourselves and for our
students our future because
we want to know what the perspectives
are and how people are feeling
that helps to solve the problem yeah i
feel like you have to come from a
genuine place where you want to know the
truth
and that might make you feel
uncomfortable that might be different
from what you were
holding on to but if you're going to go
into it already feeling like well
i already know i'm right and you know
i'm just going to find more articles to
support that thought then you're just
right back at square one
right exactly yeah i mean i was hesitant
too when
i got offered to get the vaccine at my
hospital
they're like okay here here's a sign-up
sheet do you want to put get the vaccine
yes or no i'm like well
i don't know what's in it i don't know
how is it administered so i had to
do my own research and for me i thought
me getting the vaccine benefited me more
like i'd rather get a headache than
have some other covenanting effects
and you know for me coming into this
conversation right
i was skeptical of the vaccine but i
came into it to see
what else can i learn because i think as
people all we could do
is sit back take a deep breath and look
at each other and say
how can we do better what can we learn
get out of your box
because if we don't we're going to be
stuck in this situation forever
it's going to be terrible man it's going
to be terrible these this is what's
important
i'd rather talk to you yeah i'd rather
talk to you i'd rather talk to you
which opens it up maybe just a little
bit more than it would have right but it
opens it up
this this is the key this has always
been the key
yeah this is the answer so we can do
this together folks i really believe it
there's no combination of words or
phrases that i can
tell you guys which would give you an
accurate picture of
the amount of human misery and grief and
suffering
that we have witnessed in the past year
but specifically the past
two months but i'm going to stay an
optimist
and i'm going to hope that we're going
to get over this pandemic
we're going to come together at the end
of all this
we live on one planet yep and what
happens in wuhan china
will affect you whether you live in
wichita kansas or washington dc
so my hope is that we can come together
and stop looking out for ourselves but
look out for
everyone else
are we allowed to shake hands are we
allowed to hug my elbow it's uh it's
up to whoever is right i'm here
don't touch me
you